[Music]
marie joins us in cincinnati ohio marie
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much absolutely how can
john and i help
well um i purchased the house six years
ago for 27 000.
i worked on it which i've always loved
to do and i recently sold it for uh well
actually filled it for 237 and then
after commission and
tithe and giving to my church um i have
a hundred and eighty eight thousand
way to go congratulations marie how did
you do that how many how much did you
put into it in repairs
well i did a lot of the work um
well sadly i my husband passed away
january 31st so we were doing it
together
um he's with the lord jesus it isn't
easy but it is it is um hope that you
know we will see each other so yeah we
did it together and then um
he got
sick and then i just i've always known
how to have tool time and i've always
known how to do things
um so we bought it for 27 000 when the
market was not so hot and
um
and we we put in like the things that we
couldn't repair like the roof
and the electric and the plumbing we put
in about
30 000
um and so
that's how we did it wow wow you never
once we're so sorry for your loss sounds
like your husband was an incredible guy
huh
he he really was it it's um
it was difficult really really difficult
um
but
you know it's it would be harder without
jesus so
um
you know it's it's been hard it's easier
down but i mean it's only been since
january
and it's okay for it to stay hard for a
long long time y'all were together for a
while and he sounds like he was a great
guy
and man i'm so sorry for your loss and
on the other side congratulations for
seeing this project through and
finishing it and
wow 188 thousand dollars y'all cleared
wow so what's your whole financial
picture marie are
are you okay financially obviously
you've got a big pile of money here do
you have a primary residence that you're
currently living in
well i'm actually when i sold my house
like two weeks ago uh so let's say two
and a half weeks ago i moved in with my
sister who's down the street we're super
close it's just uh she and i together
and um so my expenses went from you know
no
um
homeowners insurance or any of those
things to
my monthly expenses are like 300
i don't have a car payment i don't have
credit card debt i don't have a school
loan i just have my monthly expenses i
can live on
nothing because that's just the way we
were raised
my parents
my parents were immigrants from
santiago chile and they taught us
how to live
with little and make money in in this
beautiful america so we did what a
legacy it's awesome that's awesome so
now you're sitting here you've got no
debt and you've got a pile of cash and
you're not looking to
buy a house anytime soon because you're
living with your sister and you've got a
great situation there
right because the long-term goal is to
my i'm going to help my sister get her
house ready and then we're going to sell
her house and then we want to buy land
but
it's just the mar i just don't know what
to do with the money now because i'm not
going to be doing that for another year
and a half okay i don't want it sitting
in the bank doing nothing sure so it's
still a pretty short time horizon if
you're talking about a year you know 18
months from now so i wouldn't go you
know throwing it into the stock market
because of the volatility from you know
from now to 18 months from now you could
lose money so i get that you don't you
don't want to putting in a bank and it's
not going to grow by much you know in a
money market account or a good high
yield savings account you're probably
looking at about a half a percent and so
it's not super exciting to see that
money grow at such a slow pace but right
now what i want to do is protect this
money more than i do more than i want to
see it grow astronomically because of
the short time horizon now if you said
hey five years from now i want to do
this i would say all right let's put in
some good mutual funds and watch this
thing grow for five years
so a high yield savings account would be
your best bet right now for that 188 000
as you figure out what those next steps
are uh and make sure you have an
emergency fund in place do you currently
have three to six months of expenses i
know you don't have a lot of expenses
i don't i just have that's all i have is
188 000 to your name okay so i'm gonna
take six months of expenses which for
you that might be really low um but you
can park that in a savings account and
don't touch that that's just for
emergency situations that are unexpected
urgent and necessary so maybe fifteen
twenty thousand dollars you put in a
savings account yeah or in a checking
account
when you're when your transmission falls
out of your car it will be annoying not
catastrophic no stress got it got it do
you have anything in retirement do you
have a nest egg that you've been growing
i don't i um
i never worked corporate i raised my
sons you know as a stay-at-home mom and
then when my sons became men and they
didn't need me which was great um
i kind of went back to my love which is
i i'm an artist i just take vintage
things take them apart and put them back
together as julie and things like that
so my income has never been good and so
i've never had a retirement did your
husband leave you with any retirement
from his his professional career nothing
okay no and how old are you
i'm 54. okay
that actually changes the conversation
yeah the big question mark for me is how
are you going to live in retirement i
mean if you burned through this 188 in
cash and you bought some land you'd have
zero dollars to your name um and nothing
in retirement to even pay for those
expenses so that's my bigger
worry right now is that you may need to
get get a job to bring in some income to
start to build a nest egg for the next
you know decade and park that money
aside and maybe we don't start doing
investment property until we know we're
in a good place for retirement
do you have any sort of health insurance
life insurance anything like that
no
yeah you may want to consider not may i
strongly recommend you you sit down with
a xander representative and walk through
what it would look like to get some
health insurance over the next five 10
15 20 years were you able to cash flow
your husband's illness
no
you know the illness um
he was a he was an amazing person but he
and he did construction as his career
okay but
he
he died um
[Music]
it's kind of embarrassing even though
he's not here he died of alcohol abuse
okay okay and um and so
with that said you know he had his good
days and his bad days
um
and so he didn't leave anything he
didn't do anything as far as
savings or thinking of the future
that was always my job that was always
like put money aside or go get the
regular job or go do the shows that i
would do it was never
on his radar so marie here's what i want
to do we're going to give you
um a year's subscription to ramsey plus
and i want you to sit with your sister
and i want together i want you all to go
through every one of these lessons
together
everything from a thousand dollar
emergency fund paying off your debts
which all have already done
to
baby step three and four and building an
emergency fund and then
talking about insurance talking about
investing and it's going to lay it all
out there for you and i want you all to
do this together because you're going to
need somebody to walk alongside you and
she's going to need someone to walk
alongside her because you're going to be
learning this stuff for the first time
in your 50s
and it's going to alter your dream i'm
telling you right now it's going to
alter your dream
but it's going to be right and it might
be for the first time in 50 years
that you
sleep
all
night first time you think about the
future and your heart doesn't start
racing on you okay yeah okay okay does
that sound good
it does it's pretty cool huh to sleep
yeah
yeah not worry if we get sick we're
going to be bankrupt right
yeah and that's why i called because i
you know this is a lot of money but it's
all i have that's right so it's a lot of
money and it's not a lot of money all
the same time and marie one more step
for you i want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com click on trusted
pros i want you to get in touch with one
of our smart investor pros to teach you
what you need to do with this money when
it comes to investing i think this is
now your retirement nest egg this is not
land
yeah so that's what you need to do
appreciate the call we're rooting for
you